se sont mobilisés de mon ministère de la
santé un chiffre a encore la pandémie
qui a fait au moins 3 millions de morts
dans le monde depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
et le co vide ne fait qu'empirer la
situation déjà chaotique au yémen les
combats meurtriers entre forces
loyalistes et rebelles houthi ont montré
par ailleurs une centaine de morts à
marib localité stratégique est les
nations unies exhortent les belligérants
accepté le plan p c'était l'une de ses
promesses de campagne et augmenté le
nombre de réfugiés est venu aux états
unis joe biden conserve pourtant le
seuil fixé par son prédécesseur donald
trump quinze mille personnes par an un
seuil historiquement bas tollé du gros
chez les démocrates
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france un hommage
silencieux devant le ministère de la
santé aujourd'hui à paris un hommage
destiné aux internes qui se sont
suicidés c'est un appel de
l'intersyndicale nationale des internes
le bilan depuis le début de l'année cinq
d'entre eux se sont suicidés et chaque
année on compte une dizaine de victimes
par ailleurs plus de 700 jeunes médecins
ont déclaré une tentative de suicide et
des milliers disent avoir eu des idées
suicidaires lors d'une dernière étude
statistique en 2017
écoutez quelques témoignages recueillis
lors du rassemblement
lorsqu'il ya une vraie culture surtout à
changer cultures du monde du travail
il ya un peu ce côté ou plus on en fait
et plus on a l'impression d'être
meilleur
ça c'est une vraie problématique et qui
est entretenue par nos nos élites
médical on va dire les a je pense qu'il
ya une vraie culture a changé d'une part
et ensuite effectivement il faut plus de
monde dans les hôpitaux il faut plus de
moyens il faut plus de personnel
on demande juste que la loi soit
appliquée en france que le délit de
travail ne dépasse pas les 48 heures
passent par semaine on demande juste que
en cas de harcèlement moral harcèlement
sexuel les harceleurs les agresseurs
soient punis par la loi
en fait on rejoint complètement lisse ni
dans leur position aux demandes justes
en respect de la loi il n'y a pas
d'amélioration
le secteur de la santé on a obtenu une
petite revalorisation salariale aucun de
nos collègues mais s'est suicidé parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas assez bien payés
oui certes on aimerait être mieux payés
par rapport au nombre d'heures qu'on
fait mais c'est clairement pas le coeur
du sujet et puis les conditions de
travail nous on a des réunions en ce
moment avec la direction générale
l'organisation des soins sur les
conditions matérielles d'accueil des
internes au sein des hôpitaux
on a besoin de se battre pour rendre
l'accès à un ordinateur obligatoire dans
les bureaux des internes en est au stade
où il faut négocier les ordinateurs
autant vous dire que le reste c'est pas
gagné quoi malgré des indicateurs
toujours inquiétant l'exécutif maintient
la date du 15 mai pour la réouverture
peut-être à des terrasses et des musées
les restaurants suivront l'idée est de
descons fine et par étapes
dans un mot en ce qui concerne les
discothèques halls et salles de sport
est cotée à ce propos gabriel arduino il
est fondateur du collectif entraide tpe
nous n'avons voir de près si d'annoncer
officiellement par écrit avec des dates
fixes de réouverture comme on peut le
voir dans les pays voisins par exemple
en angleterre il aurait ouvert la
semaine dernière il avait la date de
réouverture le 22 février
donc il savait à l'avancé le calendrier
a été tenu le calendrier est tenu en
france on nous dit que c'est toujours
une hypothèse parce que c'est soumis à
la situation sanitaire du pays dans les
semaines à venir
sauf que dans les autres pays ils ont
réussi à faire pour tendre sont victimes
de la même pandémie pourquoi en france
on n'est pas capable d'avoir des
directives claires 6 et précise l'ong
union précise et certaines parce que là
ça met tout le monde dans l'embarras
sam et les acteurs économiques dans du
dans le flou complet tout le monde et
est figé tout le monde est bloqué et on
a beau avoir envie par la confiance elle
est rompue et aujourd'hui on veut c'est
des actes des images de lyon maintenant
où des centaines de personnes se sont
mobilisées contre les restrictions
sanitaires justement à 300 à 400
lyonnais ont répondu à l'appel lancé par
florian philippot contre les mesures
restrictives yeoh coronavirus et durant
la manifestation les participants
étaient non masqué y compris
leader du mouvement des patriotes a
parmi leurs revendications la
réouverture de tous les lieux publics
fermés en france
à noter aucune verbalisation pendant
l'événement écouter florian philippot et
quelques participants l'ami mais d'abord
il nous avait annoncé fin décembre le 20
janvier mi avril
mi mai et là il nous dit me mets
peut-être on verra les terrasses et
musées tout ça c'est pas possible
et dès qu'il y aura un invariant qui
débarquera tour fermé d'un coup non
écoutez il faut prendre la décision de
tout rouvrir je peux citer aussi le
texas le mississippi son tour ouvert il
ya plus d'un mois aujourd'hui les cages
sont en chute libre
alors qu'on leur avait promis d'être en
qualif c'est une décision politique
parce que ces crises des plus salutaires
et les politiques c'est pas que ça va
devoir avoir bien compris je n'y parle
qui a ce virus qui circule oui
effectivement mais bon en faire des
tonnes comme ça comme ça se passe en ce
moment non pendant le masque
distanciation sociale tous fermés ou la
ruine de l'économie
bon ce que c'est réellement justifiée
quand on voit que dans d'autres pays
ne serait ce que la suède
il y apprend tout ça c'est toute cette
politique est menée par
par emmanuel macron et le conseil
scientifique pour nous nous bruine et de
nos libertés fondamentales et face au
manque de vaccins la défiance suscitée
par astrazeneca ils sont nombreux à se
rendre ailleurs pour se faire injecter
le sérum anti qu'ovide avec l'aide des
agences de voyages destinations
notamment la russie et cela s'appelle du
tourisme vaccinale ont fait le point
avec rob actuelle le tourisme vaccinale
nouvelles tendances de la saison
printemps été 2011 21 certaines agences
de voyage proposent à leurs clients des
séjours en russie pour 1600 euros elle
organise deux voyages de quatre jours à
moscou au cours desquelles les touristes
se feront injecté à chaque fois une dose
du vaccin spoutnik vais tout est prévu
du guide pour se rendre au centre de
vaccination jusqu'à l'interprète pour le
rendez-vous médical ce jeudi 80
touristes allemands n'ont pas hésité à
décoller direction moscou
je voulais aussi me faire administrer le
vaccin avant que nous le recevrons en
allemagne à 19 ans je le recevrai bien
trop tard mon père est un patient à
risque
en fait je le fais pour lui car je veux
protéger ma famille et je ne veux pas
ramener le virus à la maison en
allemagne actuellement 6 % des personnes
sont complètement vaccinés
j'aurais probablement eu mon tour à la
fin de l'année et je ne veux pas
attendre aussi longtemps et les autres
possibilités auxquelles j'avais pensé la
serbie israël l'irak et les états unis
sont tombées à l'eau pour diverses
raisons
j'ai parcouru toutes les options
possibles et c'est l'offre numéro 1
après avoir reçu une première injection
ce vendredi les touristes allemands
effectueront deuxième voyage dans trois
semaines pour compléter leur vaccination
mais la russie n'est pas la seule
destination privilégiée par les tours
opérateurs pour développer ses voyages
vaccinaux en raison des difficultés de
lieu pour vacciner sa population de plus
en plus d'européens se renseigne à la
grande surprise des professionnels du
tourisme présents sur le créneau
notre premier marché était uniquement
l'allemagne l'autriche la suisse et nous
n'avions pas pensé à l'europe
des journalistes ont réalisé des
reportages sur nos voyages de
vaccination puis la presse allemande a
renvoyé des articles à l'étranger en
anglais et en russe et à partir de là
c'est devenu un sujet dans toute
l'europe
nous sommes dans la presse au portugal
en grèce en espagne en france
nous ne nous attendions vraiment pas à
cela c'est bien plus que ce à quoi nous
pouvions rêver
ce tourisme vaccinale s'organise même à
l'initiative de certains états le
gouvernement serbe propose par exemple
de vacciner toujours avec le spoutnik v
les ressortissants étrangers effectuant
un séjour dans le pays
une stratégie également envisagée par
cuba une fois que son vaccin sera
opérationnel un moyen de relancer le
tourisme qui a perdu 1300 milliards de
dollars rien qu'en 2020 le nombre de
morts causées par la pandémie avec 19
continue d'augmenter dans le monde la
barre des 3 millions de décès a été
dépassée aujourd'hui un martial peuvion
la mort à l'échelle industrielle à rio
de janeiro au brésil
ces constructions en béton sont
désormais la dernière demeure des
victimes du coronavirus il en existe des
dizaines dans un complexe conçu pour
accueillir des milliers de dépouilles et
ne pas surcharger les douze cimetière de
la deuxième ville du pays avant le coc
vide les gens ne souffrait pas autant il
mourrait du cancer du sida de problèmes
cardiaques
maintenant on ne parle plus de cancers
de sida ou de problèmes cardiaques
on ne parle plus que du coc vide c'est
le fléau des nations le monde entier est
piégé par le cos vide en inde pays le
plus peuplé de la planète
la situation ne s'améliore pas non plus
les ambulances déferlent dans les rues
de new delhi la capitale
alors qu'un couvre-feu est en place
depuis une semaine pour ralentir la
pandémie les locaux ont reçu l'ordre de
rester à la maison pour le week end
bien que les travailleurs des métiers
essentiels puissent se déplacer avec une
dérogation des autorités locales
car oui malgré l'accélération mondial de
la vaccination le nombre de morts
causées par le virus
ne cesse de battre des records ce samedi
17 avril 2021 la barre des 3 millions de
victimes du cobp id a officiellement été
dépassé après une légère baisse en mars
le nombre de décès quotidiens est
reparti à la hausse avec une moyenne
d'un peu plus de 12 mille morts par jour
la semaine dernière dans le monde parmi
les pays les plus touchés
citons les états unis avec plus de 560
6000 décès le brésil avec 369 1000 décès
le mexique l'inde et la france qui se
retrouve le huitième pays le plus touché
avec le cap des cent mille morts
dépasser ce jeudi à titre de comparaison
le sida a fait 698 morts en 2019 selon
l'onu et les grippes saisonnière tue
entre 290 milles et 650 mille personnes
par an quant à la grippe h1n1 le nombre
de morts qu'elle aurait causé se situe
entre 150 et 1 milles et cinq cent
soixante quinze mille personnes
ce chiffre de 3 millions semble
toutefois inférieure est réalité
et pour cause certains gouvernements
cache volontiers le nombre de morts et
de nombreux cas n'ont pas été prises en
compte au début de l'épidémie qui a
officiellement débuté à wuhan en chine
fin 2019
sans parler des pays dans l'incapacité
de tenir un registre des victimes ou
encore ceux en guerre au yémen la guerre
les différentes épidémies dont le
coville ne font qu aggraver la pire
crise humanitaire au monde selon l'onu
elle les combats entre les forces
loyalistes et les outils dans la ville
stratégique de marib à l'est de la
capitale ont fait une centaine de morts
en quelques jours à grégoire douce et
des tombes creusées les unes à la suite
des autres pour enterrer les victimes du
coc vide 19 des images éloquentes qui
montre une vérité très éloignés des
chiffres officiels de la pandémie au
yémen à peine plus de 5600 cas confirmés
de coronavirus depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire et seulement quelques
dizaines de cas quotidiens comptabilisés
en plein pic épidémique
d'après l'onu ces statistiques ne
constituent en rien le reflet de la
réalité
en cause notamment le manque de test
dans un pays ravagé par la guerre et
dont les structures hospitalières n'ont
pas les capacités pour répondre à
l'urgence sanitaire
même avec l'arrivée des vaccins les
vaccins ne suffiront pas à venir à bout
de la deuxième vague
nous avons donc un besoin sûrs
jean de plus de ressources pour
intensifier le traitement la
surveillance et d'autres activités qui
atténueront l'impact de la pandémie
et quand ce ne sont pas les capacités du
système de santé qui sont montrés du
doigt les pouvoirs publics prennent le
relais il y à de la négligence de la
part des autorités
ils n'ont pas rempli correctement leur
rôle lors de la vague précédente le
gouvernement avait pris des mesures
préventives
même si elles n'étaient pas suffisantes
pour faire face à la catastrophe
cette deuxième vague est plus intense
que la vague précédente mais les
autorités officielles de taiz n'ont pas
rempli leur devoir de protéger la vie
des gens quand les tombes individuelles
ne suffisent plus
les responsables des cimetières en sont
réduits à solliciter l'aide des
habitants pour creuser des fosses
communes
nous recevons 9 10 corps par jour nous
sommes allés chercher des fossoyeurs au
marché pour nous aider car nous ne
pouvions pas répondre à la demande de
nouvelles tombes et malgré leur aide
nous n'arrivions pas à y faire face nous
avons donc dû louer une pelleteuse pour
creuser de nouvelles tombes et enterrées
les victimes hier un fossoyeur à creuser
8 on pour autant de corps enterrés alors
que les nations unies considèrent la
situation au yémen comme la pire crise
humanitaire au monde à l'heure actuelle
la pandémie ne fait qu'empirer les
choses
depuis le début du conflit en 2014 au
moins deux cent cinquante mille
personnes ont perdu la vie est toujours
concernant le yémen écoutez l'analyse de
benoît muracciole et les présidents de
l'association as their action sécurité
éthique républicaine selon lui aucune
amélioration de la situation humanitaire
n'est possible tant que la france
continue de vendre des armes
aucune des parties est aujourd'hui prête
à cesser les combats
semble-t-il la dernière rencontre avec
les membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité l'union européenne le koweit
l'allemagne
à berlin n'a rien donné pour le moment
mais on comprend mal comment cela
pourrait trouver une issue encore une
fois si la france notamment le
gouvernement français en toute
connaissance de cause puisqu'on sait
avec les éléments de disclose révélée
par dispose que le gouvernement français
est parfaitement au courant de l usage
des armes du matériel de guerre vendues
à l'arabie saoudite aux émirats arabes
unis notamment à l'egypte et qui est
utilisé dans ces crimes contre
l'humanité eh bien on voit mal comment
une situation humanitaire aussi
terrifiante que l'hymen pourrait
s'améliorer puisque la france et la
grande bretagne notamment continuent de
défendre déjà joe biden rétropédale sans
l'immigration la journée d'hier a été le
théâtre d'un affrontement politique au
sein du camp démocrate le président a
d'abord annoncé vouloir garder le même
quota de réfugiés que donald trump en
opposition totale avec l'une de ses
promesses électorales
une décision tout de suite contesté par
une partie de son convoi sera avec félix
ul et pire ian lazar hills dans ce camp
des nations unies l'espoir pour ces
réfugiés de s'envoler aux états unis est
au coeur d'une bataille politique menée
depuis washington donald trump avait
fixé un seuil historiquement bas de
réfugiés quinze mille personnes
seulement pouvait arriver chaque année
avec ce statut
pendant sa campagne joe biden avait
promis de réhausser ce seuil jusqu'à
huit fois plus pourtant hier matin le
président américain signe un document
annonçant que le seuil resterait à 15000
cette année et reporte sine aidiez saos
décision justifiée par l'héritage de
donald trump
il nous a fallu un certain temps pour
constater et évaluer à quel point le
système de traitement des réfugiés
étaient devenus inefficaces ou en partie
détruit nous avons donc dû reconstruire
certains de ses muscles et leur mettre
en place mais je m'attends encore une
fois à ce que nous ayons plus de
nouvelles à ce sujet aujourd'hui et nous
les partagerons avec vous tous
autre raison moins avouable un contexte
migratoire extrêmement tendue à la
frontière mexicaine et des attaques du
camp républicain
en attendant tollé chez les démocrates
plusieurs hauts responsables dénoncent
cette décision et alexandria occasion
cortese représentante de l'ailé gauche
du parti
tweet s est presque 13 millions
d'abonnés sa totale opposition
complètement est totalement inacceptable
by john a promis d'accueillir les
migrants et les gens ont voté pour lui
sur la base de cette promesse soutenir
les politiques xénophobes et racistes de
l'administration trump y compris le
plafond de réfugiés historiquement bas
et dégringoler est tout simplement
inacceptable
tenez votre promesse et devant la
pression quelques heures plus tard
l'administration byden rétropédale est
en hausse
la directive du président a fait l'objet
d'une certaine confusion
le président a été invité à prendre des
mesures immédiates pour inverser la
politique de trump et nous nous
attendons à ce que le président fixe
d'ici le 15 mai un plafond de réfugiés
définitif est augmentée pour le reste de
l'année
même non chiffrée la décision est alors
saluée par alexandria occasio cortese
depuis des années 80 l'objectif annuel
du programme d'admission des réfugiés
aux états unis s'est élevée à 95 milles
personnes accueillies tous les ont un
objectif drastiquement revu à la baisse
par l'administration trump écoutez
l'analyse douglas iex il est professeur
de droit spécialiste de sciences
politiques américains il ya confusion
aux états unis entre les migrantes qui
viennent à la frontière qui cherchent
l'asile
et les réfugiés dans les camps hoài nam
frigo d'ailleurs qu'ils ont passés sous
une procédure de vêtements et qui était
agréé pour entrer aux états unis et les
autres types c'est mal perçu et pour
saab a annoncé il va laisser ce sujet
c'est trop chaud maintenant il a autres
objectifs à accomplir
je pense le pratique était de garder
fixe le 14 à 15 mieux parce que il n'ya
pas les voir dans cette d'entendre ces
choses significatives
électoralement mais bien sûr le
rétropédalage c'était essentiel pour
garde des caudal d'orb qui est le fruit
de majorité dans le senate a dit que
c'est inacceptable
il a besoin de chaque voie dans le
scénar maintenant ou d autres programmes
donc il dit oui après jusqu'ici à mes 15
c'était seulement un manoeuvre politique
c'est pas crédible
ce vendredi à assen pétersbourg un
consul ukrainien était arrêté par le
service fédéral de sécurité russe il est
accusé d'avoir tenté d'obtenir des
informations secrètes pour moscou je
cite cette activité est incompatible
avec le statut de diplomate et présente
un caractère clairement hostile à
l'égard de la fédération de russie
le diplomate devrait faire l'objet de
mesures conformes au droit international
de son côté le ministère ukrainien des
affaires étrangères dénonce une
provocation
en riposte ukraine a même annoncé
expulsé un diplomate de l'ambassade de
russie à kiev dans les 72 heures les
tensions entre l'ukraine et la russie
encore après la réunion tripartite
d'hier sur le dombass entre l'ukraine et
la france et l'allemagne
emmanuel macron annonce vouloir
s'entretenir prochainement avec son
homologue russe vladimir poutine
l'objectif demandait la russie de
retirer ses troupes de la frontière
ukrainienne
justement reportage dans un village en
contact direct avec la ligne de front à
donner à ce qu est signée de notre
envoyé spécial en train de clayrou
nous nous rendrons village d'alexandre
offrait à proximité immédiate de la
ligne de contact et au laos détention
depuis le début d'année se traduit de
façon très concrète
les bombardements sont devenus deux fois
plus fréquents alors qu'auparavant seuls
des armes légères étaient utilisés en
tire maintenant avec des canons d'un
calibre de 30 mm dspg dbm paix avec
toutes les munitions comme les unités
ukrainiennes sont officiellement entrés
dans le village nous nous sommes séparés
d'elle que par l'eau c'est-à-dire 250
mètres environ où un homme a été tué
récemment il ya eu trois incidents de ce
type au cours des deux derniers mois des
snipers isolés travail et surtout la
nuit avec un équipement sophistiqué
il ya eu deux blessés graves et un mort
les bombardements continuent tous les
jours la nuit c'est évident on entend
des tirs de snipers et d'armes légères
cela se poursuit également pendant la
journée machenaud et les métaux symbole
est encore higuain terry le bombardement
en plein centre du village avec des
baies mp2 mp3 nous avons pu recueillir
le témoignage d'alexandre un habitant du
village qui également électricien et
s'occupe de réparer les lignes
électriques
et c'est définitivement un métier à haut
risque dans le contexte actuel dès que
la guerre a commencé on a pris les
choses en main on a formé une brigade
j'ai pris ma mobylette et je suis allé
le long d'une plantation forestière
une fois que nous avons tous fait
quelqu'un nous a dénoncé et rebelote
nous avons tout fait et une heure ou une
heure et demie plus tard ils ont
commencé à bombarder ce territoire
j'ai entendu dire que vous aviez est
également touché oui plusieurs foires
c'était un miracle ou bien je suis né
coiffé sinon j'aurais pu crever la
première fois c'était en 2014 au 7 rue
kirov j'ai grimpé sur un poteau je me
suis attaché avec une ceinture et je
m'occupais d'un isolant électrique celui
tout en haut
l'obus à voler au dessus de ma tête et
s'est désintégré en morceaux j'ai
compris qu'il y avait eu un tir et qu'il
s'était désintégré
les gars m'ont crié des sanctuaires
faire tuer nous nous trouvons simplement
quelques centaines de la ligne de front
qui se situe de ce côté là et voilà le
or de surprise que les habitants de ce
village peuvent retrouver dans leur
jardin
ceci provient d'un char ça ça vient d'un
canon automoteur de 122 mm l'obus a été
désactivé ceci est un ouragan un lance
roquettes multiples cet ouragan a tué
deux personnes un jeune homme de 18 ans
et une femme de 64 ans rue kirov
ce sont des missiles à fragmentation ce
sont les missiles antichars avec
lesquels ils nous bombardent
ces deux derniers ont complètement
détruit le deuxième étage d'un bâtiment
o 9 a de la route schedule skins f
c'est un missile guidé antichars nous
avons un nombre incalculable de
munitions de canon sans recul antichars
rpg 7
nous les appelons carottes je voulais
déjà dit nous en avons compté 500 chacun
dans ce village est touché de près ou de
loin par cette guerre alors bien sûr la
peur existe la peur est présente mais il
faut bien continuer à vivre pour
l'instant il commence de nouveau à
bombarder nuit et jour et le matin le
pire c'est quand les enfants sont à
l'école près de laquelle se trouve
prétendument un kolkhoze en réalité le
poste de contrôle 0 et ils commencent à
tirer dans la journée quand les enfants
sont à l'école c'est la chose la plus
terrible maintenant on est chez soi et
on a ces enfants là bas on ne sait
jamais s'il y aura assez de temps pour
revenir on est toujours au téléphone
les parents sont ici à bout de nerfs on
l'a dit il les et malgré la menace
constante des grenades et des snipers la
vie continue les enfants vont à l'école
les personnes âgées s'occupe du jardin
du potager les gens vaquent à leurs
occupations
la vie continue car au final il n'y a
pas d'autre choix en centrafrique la
guerre civile sévit toujours entre le
gouvernement et la rébellion armée qui
tentent de renverser le président outre
les affrontements se sont aussi les
chantiers de construction qui en
subissent les conséquences reportage au
coeur de bangui la capitale avec pas
compétente j
commentaire signé maxime a bola ils sont
les victimes collatérales du conflit
armé centrafricain les chantiers de
construction tourne au ralenti depuis
plusieurs mois dans la région de bangui
mi-janvier la rébellion armée a pris
possession de nombreuses exploitations
minières et dax de ravitaillement
rendant à l'importation des matériaux
difficiles notamment en provenance du
cameroun
si l'armée a pu reprendre le contrôle de
la kz2 puis la situation instable de la
région fragilisé circulation des
approvisionnements et a fait exploser
les prix des matériaux principaux à mon
chantier est bloqué aujourd'hui parce
que les prix du ciment
on monte et on ne sait pas pourquoi le
gouvernement nous a pas encore 10 qui
sait qu'on va faire c'est pour ça que le
chantier bloqué jusqu'à la pac on attend
seulement le gouvernement pour qu'il
trouve une solution les payant doublé à
l'image du coup du sac de ciment les
matériaux sont devenus hors de prix pour
une grande partie des chantiers de
construction
certains ont dû fermer d'autres luttes
comme ils peuvent pour continuer les
travaux et cette pénurie nous a fait
perdre de temps parce que en
impossibilité de d'avoir les matériaux
quand on a besoin présentement les
ciments les fermes à chippis
on est obligé de s'adapter par rapport à
ce nouveau prix on est obligé de faire
de petits gymnastes kouaoua les sacs de
ciment peut-être dix quinze vingt
progressé à tendre la situation pourrait
tout de même évoluer dans les prochains
jours l'unité pour la paix en
centrafrique plus gros groupes armés de
la rébellion annoncé son retrait de la
coalition qui cherche à faire tomber le
gouvernement
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans 30 minutes en direct pour une
nouvelle édition
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout